dos de las mayores ciudades de china
shenzhen y shanghai se enfrentan a duras
restricciones mientras el país alcanza
su mayor índice de casos en dos años
salí con unos amigos hace unos días y
ahora les han puesto en cuarentena de
repente creo que las autoridades de
shanghai están haciendo esto para
proteger a los ciudadanos a largo plazo
esto es algo bueno
la ciudad sudoriental de sindh en
fronteriza con hong kong ha sido puesta
en aislamiento total durante los
próximos siete días los trabajadores no
esenciales tienen que quedarse en casa
el transporte público se ha detenido y
los adultos deben someterse a tres
pruebas pcr la ciudad tiene uno de los
mayores puertos del mundo lo que
significa que un 7 podría interrumpir
aún más las cadenas de suministro
mundiales en shanghai las autoridades
evitan la cuarentena masiva cerrando
escuelas y empresas individuales lo que
complica los planes para estos
estudiantes teníamos que dejar shanghai
pero ya no podemos irnos hoy el gobierno
dijo que tenemos que hacernos la prueba
del cob y las próximas 48 horas así que
eso es lo que vamos a hacer a los
residentes se les pollo y salir de
shanghai y shenzhen sin una prueba pcr
negativa causa largas colas mientras la
gente se apresura a obtener un resultado
negativo en el norte de china
continental donde los casos son más
numerosos las autoridades crearon
hospitales temporales para tratar y
aislar a los que dan positivo el país
mantiene su estricta política de kobe
19-0 ya que las valientes omicron y
delta provocan un aumento de los casos